and today we're going to talk about our
book The Coming buck in june
twenty-fourth the Declaration of
Independence
yeah you should probably just hop can
say this is we'll talk about declaration
of independence and that you know this
is a global manifesto of a different
sort I suspect it will be the only
political book this year which name
checks the shock rock band wars and out
of this toilet earth also have many
other folks will have my incentives
along the lines of if the only choices
we have our between Nancy Pelosi and
John Boehner the survivors will indeed
the day speaking of choices recent
Federation recent magazine recent
conduct to be the same tech world that
choice I just have rear a fellow guy
Scotty mine who was on G and cruised and
as a world traveler sent this photo
which I thought everybody would think I
got a gesture day from him he was in
Russia this is the Moscow this is a
famous statue of marks and you'll note
at the bottom he put his reason took
their high of a fantastic rollin ask we
seem to be helped us up following the
Soviet Union into the dustbin of history
as a free market economy it's were
thinking I think you know uh as many of
you know lady Friedlander of the
gentleman who actually started reason
I've seen as a student in Boston
University in 1960 died a few weeks ago
and it's amazing certainly at lannie's
dream I'm sure when he started the
magazine and he had no idea that would
turn into this foundation and
intergalactically but you've got a think
tank and what have you done thanks that
I think people argue but also that he
would live in a world where the Soviet
Union know for sure existed and in many
ways we've achieved a lot of freedom
which is actually a lot of what the book
is about so the story points of the
Declaration of Independence for us we're
really that you know at nine and mostly
be that is really a commie simple don't
be explaining that it a little bit but
we believe that life is best for
politics is least and where
decentralization of the mantra is asian
of power and decision-making is greatest
and most dispersed and that you know
this is basically classical liberalism
the idea that concentrations of power
are bad thing that also individuals have
some kind of inherent dignity I have
used up all my inherent dignity and
taking on as much debt to bring dignity
back as possible to me but that you know
we have the right to live our lives the
way we want to as long as we're not you
know massively infringing on other
people's rights or even minimally an
infringing on other people's rights so
that's a big starting point and then you
know the kind of a dinner party a
conversation question which is just why
do we have more choices at a starbucks
or you know at a coffee shop than we do
at the ballot box and not necessarily
talking about you know we we can either
vote republican or democratic but you
know why do the two parties look so much
alike i mean there's obvious structural
reasons why we have two parties that are
dominant in the in US history i mean
those parties have changed over time
what Democrats and Republicans stand for
or stand against has changed over time
but it's always two parties it's always
going to be two parties because we have
a first-past-the-post system but why
don't we have more Ron Paul's in the
Republican Party why don't we have you
know more joe Manchin's the interesting
west virginia's senator in the
Democratic Party have been the governor
of West Virginia got an a from the Cato
Institute and their governor Governor
rapporto last year you know why do why
does every you know I guess I'm a bad
person to say this but when you think
about political parties and politicians
it's like what Henry Ford said about
customers picking their own color of a
car they can have whatever color they
want as long as it's black in the
Republicans and Democrats it's just
endless replication of the same boring
useless people for the most part and
then finally what really got us going on
the book project was that we recognize
that people up in fleeing identification
with Democrats and Republicans for years
this is a tire series from the the
Gallup poll that starts back in 1988 and
goes forward to 2010 and one of the
things that you can see is that
Republicans and Democrats now are less
popular than people who this is what
they ask how do you regardless of how
you've regardless of your registration
how do you what do you consider yourself
how do you identify yourself and what
has happened over time is that the
number of people who say I'm an
independent has risen and the people who
say I'm a Democrat or a Republican has
faded and there is no question across a
wide variety of measures that party
identification of people say you know
what I've got maybe three or four things
that I say I am I am a man i am from New
Jerry I am an American I'm from New
Jersey I'm a father what
it the likelihood that people are
strongly going to say I'm a Republican
around with Democrat is fading because
people don't like those brands anymore
and with that you know and so what we're
seeing well we talked about the
Declaration of Independence independent
voters are absolutely where the action
is everybody recognizes that certainly
the the major parties do because that's
who they're going after they've got
their base and they've each got about a
third of the population so it's the
people in the middle we're going to talk
about who are the independence and why
they might be libertarian and why we
might reach them and now some political
watchers are saying this could be the
nastiest most negative election season
of all time this campaign season seems
like candidates have taken dirty to a
whole new level when plundered starts
shouting and politicians start calling
each other's names it can seem like a
return to civility is not possible like
the very idea is a relic of some bygone
bygone era John Adams he's a blind bald
crippled toothless man who wants to
start a war with France while he's not
busy importing mistresses from Europe
he's trying to marry one of his sons to
a daughter of King George haven't we had
enough monarchy in America I'm Thomas
Jefferson and I approve this message
because John Adams is a hideous enough
rigidity character with neither the
force and firmness of a man with a
gentleness and Sensibility of a woman if
Thomas Jefferson wins murder robbery
rape adultery and incest will be openly
taught and practiced the air will be
rent with the cries of the distressed
the soil will be soaked with blood and
the nation black with crimes are you
prepared to see your dwellings in flames
female chastity violated children
writhing on a pike I'm John Adams and I
proved this message because Jefferson is
the son of a half-breed indian squall
raised on hoe cakes and hamilton is a
creole bastard brat of a scotch peddler
the nastiest most negative election
aides have taken dirty to a whole new
you can seem like a return to civility
is not possible we're trying to bring
back the hoe cake will be a just don't
see how it can be an insult so the
question is independents are every
single new polling period independents
are reaching something close to a brand
new high since 1970 independents have
gone from roughly seventeen eighteen
percent to now it's 38 approaching forty
percent every new polling period most
recently I that I saw for my thing
gallop in January Democrats are at an
all-time low that the trend lines are
unmistakable so who are these
independents what do we know about them
there is a school of thought and
unsurprisingly it is a school of thought
that is tethered or championed by people
who tend to be more partisan than
perhaps the people in this room that
independence are just morons for the
most part they're people who can't come
up with their own preferences they don't
follow politics enough and then we all
know that's a terrible thing to do and
that they are basically they are
partisans but they don't really know it
on jonah goldberg uh i wrote a memorable
column about that in the LA times a year
or so ago on the left you hear people
say that we are in the midst of and this
is something that Emily can talk to you
about more detail because she's an
actual professional about this stuff but
that we're we're in a polarization
moment where Democrats and Republicans
are actually becoming more polarized and
so our independence themselves they are
more polarized than they have been for a
long time that they roughly mirror the
two major parties these are sort of
self-serving narratives because the two
major political parties don't want there
to be anything else they don't want any
disruption in their world
unpredictability in their world the fact
is which we'll get into a little bit
later
they independents specifically are
creating a new unpredictability in the
political process and the two major
parties are panicking the short answer
to who or beginning of an answer to who
these people are is simply who they vote
for and we find out that they're
basically the swing vote at this moment
you can see independence brought back
Democrats specifically in 2006 and they
rogue Obama and the Democrats to party
in to power in 2008 look at that body
number for independence at Obama be that
number came out of think this morning
independents are now thirty five percent
favorability rating for Barack Obama
after being 56% just a year and change
ago that's a real bad number for him
he's got the he's got some issues
independence in Congress as you can see
there are screaming violently back and
forth that for 233 number it's a
different source and the other one so I
don't know how strong it is but you can
see with the recent unpleasantness in
Washington that it could be that they're
swinging now against the perceived
meanness of Republicans slide please
I've wanted to do this for a really long
time yeah this is just sort of an
interesting bobble out there the Tea
Party movement which I think in many
respects is just the most interesting
thing that's happened to American
politics in the last two decades over
many ways to see where independence fit
in with them and basically they don't
know about the Tea Party too much and as
they're starting to know more they are
starting to to like them a little bit
less a higher on favorability rating
although the favorability remains pretty
constant I am shocked that there is any
poll of anybody whether they're
independent or not that is favorable the
Tea Party considering just the
horrendous press the Tea Party has
gotten from the beginning as a
retrograde racist you know barely
ape-like movements
of angry white people it's it's
astonishing on a daily basis and it's
something that we have been writing
about in attending these rallies and
doing a lot of recent TV videos the gap
between the normal portrayal of the Tea
Party and the kind of things that we
talked to when we actually you know
interview a tea party person there's a
Rand Paul had a great speech on the
Senate floor I think just yesterday or
the day before challenging his
colleagues to actually meet a tea party
person talk to them before ever
describing them again slide please man
so question is how a libertarian are
they worse the libertarian bowed where's
the overlap here it's been a series of
interesting studies by David bows and
Dave Kirby affiliated with the Cato
Institute and we are thankfully starting
a series of much more interesting
studies and out here no the polling
project for us is going to be it's going
to be phenomenal because we're going to
be getting at people's actual
preferences and not trying to skew the
results to sell one party or another and
try to figure out what the sense of
trade-offs are and and now where people
think um interesting had lied to me the
most interesting thing about the David
bhosle well first of all the basic
number that they've come up with it
there's a fourteen percent of the vote
in the country that can be reliably
described as libertarian according to
their sort of definitions and that's up
from around nine percent in 1990 they
have a broader number of people in
America carving through poles who
describe themselves as fiscally
conservative socially tolerant and that
number can goes highs fifty-nine percent
and in any polling that you look at
those numbers are on the rise
particularly since 2008 and n tarp and
all the unpleasant it does come since
then libertarians themselves when they
self-identify if you take that fourteen
percent more than half of them don't
call themselves libertarian and many of
them have never even heard
the word so people who have the tendency
don't know the label the label is more
of a self conscious thing that people
have been talking about in think tanks
and in sort of self conscious political
movements over the last four decades as
you can see a quarter of libertarians
call themselves independents in general
and especially the Ron Paul libertarians
campus libertarians outspoken can tell
you about those people are actually
independent and not necessarily subsets
of the Republican Party Ron Paul
supporters did not like John McCain
whereas if you look at the broader
libertarian vote it still went fifty
three percent for john mccain would
highlight just those numbers there this
is the kind of a great Cold War split
right before 19 before the end of fall
of communism libertarian vote was more
or less a subset of the Republican Party
and afterwards it's much more up for
grabs and if you break it down by
congressional elections every two years
those trends are just on the increase um
slide yes sir I can't tell you the exact
seventy to eighty eight ones but for the
presidential elections in 2000 2004 and
2008 it goes basically i believe it was
forty-six percent bush this is 2020
thirty two percent third party and ten
percent gore into 2000 2004 and my neva
number here are two wrong I mean it was
something like thirty four percent bush
note 40 something percent bush
twenty-six percent third party and
fifteen percent Kerry and then in two
thousand eight fifty three percent
McCain again twenty six percent third
party and fifteen percent Obama so it's
moving around basically it and the and
the congressional by-elections is even
more violent he was basically 7020 in
two thousand
2002 Republicans versus Democrats with a
you know six percent other and then in
two thousand and six and eight who's
essentially fifty-fifty or close to it
and that is now in that change violently
again in 2010 which which tracks
independence independence as we saw
previously we're super Democrat in 2006
and 08 in the congressional elections
and then flipped it went super
Republican or 2010 as we talked about
before word with Nick so why is this why
are we seeing this increase why are they
behaving this way um would argue that
largely it's because the two main brands
i mean we think about duopoly is an old
and tired duopoly is out there in the
culture these are just tired duopoly Z
or geriatric Jawad leagues they've been
around since basically the 19th century
and what do classic duopoly is do
everywhere in the market they basically
take their captive audience and they
treat them like captives this is true
even in the private sector where you
don't have a guaranteed revenue stream
which you do in politics if you and even
when you look there at a place like what
are the two main of beer companies its
Miller Coors and and anheuser-busch
inbev is that the what they're called
now that's eighty percent of the beer
market right now and they treat
customers like captives they give you
really crappy stuff that they charge you
too much money for their market shares
going down like this and sales are down
a year in year or at least flat it's the
other twenty percent it's the long tail
of the beer market where people do have
a choice and are doing interesting
experiments its craft beer its anchor
steam which we've been drinking this
weekend thanks to Manny that is on the
increase that grows ten percent twelve
percent it's where customers can create
their own workarounds create their own
products they are they're fleeing we
don't really have that option the two
main ways that I see that sort of causes
for people to flee the brands right now
or precisely because Republicans have
sold themselves forever as the party of
limited government and they just haven't
been there starting to talk about it now
for the first time since 1994 but the
story that they tell themselves and they
tell the country
has not been true same with Democrats
they've been telling themselves and the
country where the party of civil
liberties were the party of anti-war
limited war that's also not true and
people who are everywhere else in their
lives speciated hyphenating themselves
wildly they don't find themselves served
by these two brands and with that Nick I
believe we have a video to illustrate
that concept all you can say about the
two thousands
the 2004 the absolute worst decade at
least since the 99 want box fuzzy
Matlock bah fuzzy math och box fuzzy man
lock box as you man the worst thing
about Gordy Bush was that one side had
to win brownie you're doing a heck of a
job god damn it what up Bush hadn't
dodged that well Cynthia Tom Barney
there's no easy way to say this we're
out of money I don't know what's more
disturbing that he's talking to a dog
like David Berkowitz or that he told
Barney two years before he told the rest
of us that were out of money awesome
what
you need all of them the sad thing is
she might be smarter than Joe
cock-hungry with a stock market crash
Franklin Roosevelt got on television
that's the most persistent I understand
Reagan could do that with the size
reporting for duty no wonder we lost
Vietnam that ain't do anything wrong I
have nothing hi I like that guy's hair
at been unfaithful to Iowa I was wrong
I'm sorry I'm truly sorry please let me
apologize i miss the 90's when our
politicians had sex in actual rooms will
you please stop dancing this is the clip
reel of the Damned
he's always had a problem with exit
strategy we all remember Bobby Kennedy
was assassinated I've now been in 57
states why why aren't we questioning the
underlying premise of the need for a
bailout with taxpayers money any time
Dennis Kucinich is the voice of reason
you know you're really screwed the Nobel
Peace Prize for 2009 is to be avoided to
piston Barack Obama worst decade ever
and he had me war goes to Thanks okay so
so what do we do with the info that
we've compiled in Declaration of
Independence you know what do we do with
the fact that the major parties have
leaking market share that the government
in many ways is out of control in a way
that was really is not just stunning but
it's also you nobody would have been
predicting this ten years ago or more
the way in which government is spending
you know in since bill clinton left
office total federal outlays adjusted
for inflation have increased over sixty
percent and between paul ryan's budget
plan and obama's budget plan the choices
are are we going to increase spanning
over the next decade by thirty percent
or fifty percent in Bill Clinton's last
year in office the government the
federal government spent eighteen
percent of GDP Ryan over the next decade
with average 20 and a half percent of
GDP Obama would be twenty-three percent
of GDP I mean these are odd shifts you
know where things are just ratcheting up
and up so what we do and
in the Declaration of Independence what
we offer are a couple of ways of
addressing these issues and at first and
foremost what we do is focus on what
Matt was talking about that in our
personal lives and our economic lives
and our cultural lives and our family
lives in our sexual lives we are
hyphenating more and more at least in
the states where it's legal and you know
there is a huge amount of innovation and
change and kind of customer appeal that
is going on I mean you know when you
think about what you can get on TV what
you can get on the internet what you can
get sent to your home as long as you're
not in Washington DC and a fan of John
stylianos films you can get just about
anything without anybody taking issue
with it when it comes to the public
sector that's not true especially in
three areas education health care and
retirement where the government still
dominates and to go back to the idea of
democratization and decentralization of
power and decision-making we don't have
the amount of decision making or
decentralization of power when it comes
to K through 12 education especially
health care we already you know with if
the government is spending fifty percent
of all healthcare healthcare dollars and
if Obamacare goes through as planned
that will mostly be gone or everything
will be subject to regulation or dictate
from the from the federal government in
the state government and retirement
where because of the way that Medicare
because of the way that Social Security
is set up we are basically locked into
really bad retirement plans that suck up
a lot of the money that younger and
poorer people would have to start paying
for their retirement or saving for the
retirement and instead you get locked
into a system as Social Security returns
now for current retirees a little bit
less than two percent a year on the
amount of money if it had
and other types of investments for
people who are twenty years away from
retiring and whatnot the it's almost
certain that the net the net returns on
your investment on the payroll taxes
that get thrown into what's called a
retirement plan but there is no lock
boxes Al Gore finally was running on
which would have been a nice thing but
it'll be a negative return so what we do
is we focus on those three areas where
the government still dominates and then
we talked about how traditional
approaches to solving these problems or
making have brought us to ruin too we
are so out of money moment which is a
recurring theme both of Reason magazine
of reason.com in our videos and
certainly in the book where when you
look at things you know at the federal
level we've got right now a 14 billion
or 14 trillion dollar debt which is
essentially the equivalent of the
economy at the state level we have
shortfalls basically about 48 states out
of 50 have definite shortfalls over the
next two year budgeting period and they
it's not going to come back any time
soon I live I pay taxes in Ohio and John
Kasich was elected as a real government
cutter and he's you know a fiscal Hawk
and we know this because of his time in
Congress and then he warned people I'm
going to release a budget this was a
month ago I'm going to release a budget
and you know get ready for some real
changes the real change of the top line
result is that he increases spending
over two years by eleven percent and
that's austerity right you know so and
then you know I've been at the local
level as well Paul finds Alex Manning's
excellent video about Sandy Springs
Georgia which you saw before that has a
stagnant about the hundreds of billions
of dollars that cities localities all
over the country have as an
get that coming up so you know we are
out of money and what's good about that
is that it gives us the opportunity to
start talking about what you stop doing
as a government or how you reform things
because there really is no option
anymore I mean one would hope and when
you look at politicians and this
includes people like Rand Paul and Ron
Paul and Mike Lee the senator from Utah
a variety of other people who are
putting out serious plans the Republican
Study Committee which pretty much
rubber-stamped every increase that
George Bush wanted to put into the
federal budget have actually come up
with a with a plan that would restrain
spending would bring it back down to
kind of two thousand euro levels which
is good so we provide proof of policy
alternatives in each of these things we
talked about how federal government can
be restrained through essentially mild
cuts and expected growth over the next
decade and by the end of the 2020 we
could have a balanced budget with some
money left over and that's that's not
even been really breaking a sweat that's
actually pretty easy to do we take a lot
of ideas from people like Lisa snow and
Claire Mullen about school choice and
about devolvi decision making and and
responsibility to the local level to the
parental level to the school level and
when it comes to retirement we come up
with a bunch of different ways in
healthcare which will be familiar to
people who read reason and follow it but
always the proven solutions are about
democratization and decentralization of
giving individuals more power to make
more decisions about what matters most
of them it because they best know what
they want and they know best how to deal
with it and with
we're going to go to one more video
assuming there where you are
thanks for tuning in to budget chef on
reason TV i'm nick gillespie today we're
going to prepare a balanced budget by
the year twenty twenty and for a special
treat we're going to do this without
raising taxes now at first it seems like
a really complicated dish but in fact
it's so incredibly simple that virtually
any elected officials should be able to
pull it off all you have to do is spend
no more than you're taking in this big
piece of pork here represents the
combined budgets for the next ten years
in order to balance the budget in 2020
what we need to do is to find a total of
1.3 trillion dollars in cuts or about a
hundred and thirty billion dollars a
year in each of the next ten years that
sounds like a lot until you realize you
only need to trim three-point-six
percent of each year's budget so here's
the budget for 2011 to get started on
the balanced budget all we need to do is
to cut this little piece of fat right
here now let's work on the next nine
budgets you know with this dish you'll
Wow your trading partners and foreign
and domestic investors and by making
small systematic cuts in the fatty parts
of the budget over the next decade will
compounder our savings and here's 2020s
budget which is projected to come in at
about five trillion dollars but because
we trimmed all this fat this is looking
pretty edible it wasn't so hard was it
if you want the full recipe for how to
balance the budget without raising taxes
you'll find it online of reason.com now
lets roast this baby bone appetit
um we're trying to be part of the
serious policy debate in Washington is I
am very happy in the unplanned accident
that this will be the second book that
I'm involved with and both are at heart
attacks on David Brooks my first book
was about John McCain and specifically
his embodiments of the project that
David Brooks and Bill Kristol started in
1997 of national greatness conservatism
were kind of progressive conservatism
Messi's later described it which is a
more muscular very strongly
interventionist both economically and
militarily abroad and and just fiscally
reckless on every level as a part of a
way to sort of cleanse our national
consciousness and everyone is going to
have national service and and everything
else with it Dave Brooks wrote that 1997
one of the first great critiques that
became from Virginia postural than
editor of Reason magazine and a dear
friend of all of us here attacked it
rightly as a recipe for big government
and vague and ominous sounding plans
Brooks lost in two thousand there can
candidate was John McCain and they lost
to george w bush who i know we don't
remember it now but he ran on a more
humble foreign policy and more
decentralized this isn't that after
September eleventh he took a much more
David Brooks in line and from that
moment on the columnist focused on
trying to build a permanent governing
majority and I sometimes just try to
think what would my brain have to work
like how would I draw the six and move
my foot if I woke up in the morning you
know how can we come up with a permit
governing majority of my tribe just as
there's something there's something
about that to me that just sounds a kind
of frightening Lee authoritarian right
before the 2004 Republican National
Convention which itself was a pretty
frightening clea authoritarian
experience for some of us who went there
dear Brooks came up with a very long
cover story for new york times magazine
that i encourage all of you to reread
about once a year just to refrain
yourself about where we can go again and
where he talked about we're going to
build a permanent governing majority of
republicanism once we ditch
libertarianism once and for all which he
always mentions by name and if we
embrace this progressive conservatism
the era of limited government is over he
declared if only we spend a lot more
money on education on solving problems
and restoring our sense of national
honor as in a lot of things with David
Brooks all his predictions were wrong
and yet everybody followed his advice
the Republicans under george w bush went
on a memorable spending [ __ ] which we
all know and right about the time that
Brooks wrote this we had the beginning
of something basically opposite of what
you say instead of a permanent governing
majority of big spending Republicans we
have now entered into an era thanks to
both technology and what we've all
learned from the internet and all the
advances in their lives where it's more
about the permanent non governing
minority a series of disaffected people
who were tired of the political status
quo who used the tools in the private
sector to disrupt and and make
uncomfortable the sclerotic status quo
call these online swarms you can date it
back to 2000 if you want i think 2004 is
really the first great iteration of this
democrats historically have had a pretty
strong or at least vocal anti-war wing
us specifically when a republican is the
president obviously but that wing had
gone disrespected for a long time bill
clinton especially in the second term
turned out to be a big interventionist
democrats kept a nominating or
supporting people who differentiated
themselves as tough democrats by being
more Pro intervention but the 2004
presidential campaign this led the
ignoring this tradition
led to a big backlash and swarm which
coalesced around the character of howard
dean is no accident that when you saw
this backlash this therefore became the
most internet savvy wing of modern
American politics because the Internet
is what the disaffected used to gather
themselves so which is all ironic as
Howard Dean was in favor of four of the
previous five interventions but he just
didn't like Iraq so 2003-2004 that
online swarm was the Howard Dean
Democrats notably the Democrats hired
him then to be the chair of the National
Committee which we talked about a second
2006 I think you could say the online
swarm was more about Bush derangement
syndrome it was the high rival which I
still suffer from by the way it was the
high-water mark of the liberal net roots
they were ascendant they memorably took
on Joe Lieberman with an anti-war
candidate ned lamont and then ended up
losing in the general election to joe
lieberman again but that's where that
was centered 2008 I think we had to
online swarms there was still the
anti-war contingent net roots that
coalesced around Barack Obama who at one
point was not everyone's favorite
candidate but he was the most sort of
strong and articulate ant iraq war and
then there's the Ron Paul revolution
which obviously I find much more
interesting on some level but again
which was speaking to both the anti
interventionist tradition in there on
the right wing and then among young
people but specifically about the
Republican you know a wing of the
Republican Party the idea that we should
be about limiting government and
promoting free enterprise which have
been completely lost on all of these
things become the most Internet sad Ron
Paul ran the most internet savvy
campaign of anyone at 2008 which is
pretty bizarre for a 70 year old who
probably still hasn't used the internet
yet in this life on 2010 if you look at
the disrespected American tradition that
was being disrespected by both parties
people who hated the bailouts we've had
a two-party bailout system since
September of 2008 and the Tea Party has
risen up specifically against that
there's
American tradition of like you don't you
let people fail and the Tea Party has
risen up using the internet again more
sophisticated than anybody else and
coalesced what does this mean going
forward I think that's where we're in
the most interesting territory the Tea
Party unlike the Howard Dean movements
and now and the anti-war movement never
got domesticated her hasn't yet Howard
Dean subsumed himself in the Democratic
Party and now there is no anti-war
movements anymore that is essentially
finished the Tea Party has like the
Democrats did with joe lieberman they
have entered some races lost some races
and shown that they're just crazy enough
to not be Republicans and in our
argument therefore have maintained their
potency it is the independence it's
their outside earnest that have allowed
them and to remain powerful and I think
they will continue being powerful
throughout 2012 however going forward
any tradition in America that is
disrespected by both parties and that
has a venerable tradition is susceptible
to the same thing I would look for and
I'm not just saying this cuz Rob camp
use in the room but in 2012 you'll see
something similar happen coalescing
around the drug war it specifically the
legalization of prop 19 in California in
2010 which distanced it went further
than even marijuana activists had wanted
them to go was a sign that finally
people who trend towards Democrats
because they liked them on issues of
drug war realized that that has been
hollow and there's nothing behind it
forever and so we're going to see full
legalization I think in a handful of
states in 2012 some of the areas where
we're going to see these online storms
are not going to be friendly to
libertarians at all but that is the
future of American politics because it
is so easy to take what we've learned
from the private sector and inflict it
on the public sector Declaration of
Independence name of the book we have
the TS they have the c/e it's a great
document to reread and not just because
of the tales of you know Indian savagery
and another element
but that we tend to forget great source
code we talk a lot about the concept of
source codes both in this document and
in other documents in the American
literature they don't talk about life
and liberty and the pursuit of politics
it's not the pursuit of meet the press
or face the nation it's life liberty the
pursuit of happiness I think embedded in
that is an idea that is wonderful and
radical and it turned out to be correct
that the stuff worth living the stuff
worth having and doing was the stuff
that you could do away from the scene of
politics there's an acknowledgement that
if the government gets out of your way
you are going to do interesting things
you might fail you might have trouble
but you're going to be able to pursue
your dream I think within that shows us
where we go from here we take what we've
learned pursuing that happiness and not
pursuing meet the press and politics and
we use it because we're in another
moment that's also embedded in the
source code which is when in the course
of human events unfortunately we are in
the course of human events we don't have
the option to sit this one out as much
as we might have had in the past we're
running out of money they're inflicting
it on us on our grandchildren and so
going forward we're going to have to
take what we've learned through the
pursuit of happiness and inflict it back
on politics so we can begin to get our
country in our lives back in order and
with that Nick I think you're going to
show an example of how we pursue
happiness in modern America
that's as good as well notice any tear
and on
you